for many Congolese camps like this one
in busagara are home at least for now
mother of nine furana bimbolesa fled her
Village last year fighting between M23
Fighters and government forces in North
kivu Province made it unsafe she's one
of many forced to flee due to worsening
insecurity Amnesty International accuses
rebels of war crimes including summary
executions forced recruitment of
civilians and mass rape
well farana has sought safety here with
no income and limited food she faces new
challenges
our life's very different here since we
left our village where I used to farm my
own food and Supply to my family but
here in the camp we are only receiving
20 kilos of maize which we need to eat
for almost two weeks it's not easy to
survive with that
also fled his home with his family and
there's not enough to eat
if the government believes they are not
able to send us back home they need to
add more food for us in this Camp so
that we can properly feed our kids
because in the village we used to eat
sufficiently all the time and different
foods as well
away from their farms and markets people
rely on food rations from the government
While others rely on International Aid
agencies
these conflicts with the M23 and the
emergencies in Italy worry us enormously
we don't have enough financing yet even
though there has been fundraising we
still need more advocacy with donors and
the international committee are still
going on in case of the DRC
Aid agencies say the DRC has the highest
number of internally displaced people in
the world at least 6 million have fled
the conflict in north kivu and militias
fighting in the East that fight for
control as well as the huge number of
those in need is making it difficult to
meet demand
to help them cope the humanitarian
organizations say they need more money
Al Jazeera